♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WE ARE
EXPECTING THE RELEASE OF THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ON
DEEP STATE FISA ABUSE, THAT'S
COMING IN JUST A FEW WEEKS.
AND FROM WHAT WE ARE HEARING
FROM SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM,
IT'S GOING TO BE "UGLY AND
DAMNING" FOR THE OBAMA AND
OFFICIALS THAT SPIED ON THE
CAMPAIGN.
I WATCHED YOUR INTERVIEW, AND I
KNOW YOU PRETTY WELL.
I WANT TO TAKE MY TIME, I WANT
TO DO IT RIGHT, AND I WANT
AMERICA TO READ ALL OF IT.
LET ME INTERPRET LINDSEY GRAHAM
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> YOU HAVE A LOUSY SOUTHERN
ACCENT, BY THE WAY.
>> Sean: SURE.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD BY PEOPLE, WHEN
EVERYTHING COMES OUT, IT WILL
SHOCK THE CONSCIENCE OF A
NATION.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> WELL, HERE'S WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO -- YEAH, I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY DAMNING AND
UGLY, AND PEOPLE DID SOME REALLY
BAD THINGS THAT ARE DANGEROUS
FOR THE COUNTRY.
BUT YOU WILL ONLY FIND IT ON
FOX.
YOU MAY FIND IT A LITTLE BIT IN
THE PAPER.
HERE'S WHAT I PREDICT: IT WILL
BE 10% OF THE COVERAGE THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT GOT.
AND THAT'S A SHAME.
SO JUST KEEP DOING WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
HERE'S THE QUESTION, IT'S NOT
WHAT DID OBAMA KNOW AND WHY DID
HE KNOW IT -- WHO TOLD HIM?
AND WHAT DID HE DO WHEN HE WAS
TOLD?
I WANT TO KNOW WHO BRIEF TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT --
>> UNRAVEL A LITTLE HERE.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT
ANDY McCARTHY?
>> WHEN YOU FIND THE PERSON WHO
BRIEF THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: ANDY McCARTHY'S
CONTENTION, THERE IS NO
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE --
>> DEAD RIGHT --
>> Sean: UNLESS IT COMES FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
IT IS THE PRESIDENT'S
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
>> A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY FROM FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATION.
THE FISA WARRANT IS A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE ACT.
IT IS NOT A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
THEY FOUND OUT THAT
DIANNE FEINSTEIN'S DRIVER MAY
HAVE HAD CONNECTIONS TO THE
CHINESE INTELLIGENCE SERVICE.
THEY TELL HER, AND SHE FIRES
HIM, RIGHT?
WHY DID THEY NOT TELL
DONALD TRUMP THAT WE BELIEVE
SOME PEOPLE IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
MAY HAVE CONTACTS WITH THE
RUSSIANS?
WHY DID THEY TELL FEINSTEIN AND
NOT TRUMP?
DID THEY ABUSE THE FISA PROCESS?
DID THEY DEFRAUD THE COURT?
DID THEY OPEN UP A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, NOT TO PROTECT
THE COUNTRY, BUT TO GET TRUMP?
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT
WILL BE SOON ANSWERED.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I READ IN
THE NEW NAZ MEMO AND THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO, THE BULK
OF INFORMATION FOR EACH
FISA WARRANT WAS THE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
OKAY.
WE KNOW, IN FACT, THE FBI AND
DOJ -- EVERYONE WAS WARNED AT
LEAST TWICE, ONCE BY BRUCE OHR,
ONCE BY KATHLEEN KAVALEC, YOU
CAN'T TRUST IT, IT'S UNVERIFIED,
CLINTON PAID FOR IT, AND STEELE
HATES TRUMP.
THEY USED IT ANYWAY.
THEN WE FIND OUT, WE JUST
DISCUSSED WITH JOHN SOLOMON,
THEY NEVER CORROBORATED ANY OF
IT, AND WHEN THE FBI FINALLY GOT
AROUND TO IT, AROUND THE TIME OF
THE THIRD RENEWAL, THE SECOND OR
THIRD RENEWAL, THEY REALIZED --
THIS IS BASICALLY ALL, TOTAL,
90% PLUS B.S.
WHY DIDN'T THEY KNOW THAT WHEN
THEY SIGNED THE FIRST WARRANT?
OR DID THEY COME AND THAT MEANS
IT'S PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON THE
FISA COURT?
>> IT WOULD BE UGLY AND DAMNING
IF YOU COULD PROVE THAT THE
DOCUMENT THEY USED TO GET THE
WARRANT, WITHOUT WHICH THERE
WOULD BE NO WARRANT, WAS NOT
VERIFIED UNTIL LATER, THAT THEY
PUT NO EFFORT INTO VERIFYING THE
DOCUMENT BEFORE THEY GAVE IT TO
THE COURT.
THEY PANICKED.
HEY, WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT IF
THIS THING ACTUALLY IS TRUE.
I WANT THE CHART DISCLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC.
I WANT TO TELL THE TRUTH,
NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH.
I WANT TO TELL THE STORY.
I WANT TO DECLASSIFY EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN DECLASSIFY, SO THE
STORY TELLS IT SELF.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
I THINK THEY PUT NO EFFORT INTO
VERIFYING THE DOCUMENT NO MATTER
DOSSIER UNTIL AFTER THEY GOT THE
WARRANT, AND WHEN THEY TRIED TO
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP W
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP T
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP H
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP A
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP D
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP Y
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP H
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP L
WEAR IF I HAD TO, THEY CAME UP .
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING TWO
PEOPLE HERE, PAPADOPOULOS AND
CARTER PAGE.
I BET YOU DONALD TRUMP DID NOT
SPEND 10 MINUTES WITH BOTH OF
THEM.
>> Sean: I COULD GUARANTEE IT.
DID YOU SEE THE GANG OF
8 BRIEFING MATERIALS, WHERE THE
FBI IDENTIFIED ALL THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF THIS NARRATIVE
IN 2018?
THE SUMMER OF 2018?
DO YOU SEE THAT, SIR?
>> NO, I DID NOT, BECAUSE I'M
NOT IN THE GANG OF 8, BUT I WANT
YOU TO SEE IT.
AND THIS IS NOT GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY THAT WILL BE
COMPROMISED.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION INTO
YOUR GOVERNMENT AND HOW IT
OPERATED.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD WANT TO
KNOW AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
EVERY MEDIA OUTLET SHOULD BE
DOING WHAT THESE OTHER GROUPS
ARE DOING, SUING TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT.
I'M GOING TO MEET THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THIS WEEK TO
TALK TO HIM ABOUT HOW TO BEST TO
TELL THE STORY.
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
CONJECTURE AS TO WHAT HAPPENED.
I WANT YOU TO READ IT.
I WANT YOU TO SEE ALL THE 302S
WE CAN POSSIBLY GET TO YOU.
I WANT YOU TO SEE THE FULL FISA
WARRANT APPLICATION.
I WANT TO RELEASE THE
TRANSCRIPTS OF THE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANTS TALKING TO
PAPADOPOULOS.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR, IN REAL
TIME, THAT THE GUY SAID, I'M NOT
WORKING WITH --
>> Sean: SENATOR --
>> IF I WERE, IT WOULD BE A
CRIME AND TREASON.
>> Sean: THE FOLLOWING I ASK
YOU: DO YOU BELIEVE, IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD, HILLARY CLINTON
COMMITTED MULTIPLE FELONIES AND
THEY RIGGED HER INVESTIGATION?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY USED AN
UNVERIFIED CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR IN RUSSIAN THAT LATER
TURNS OUT TO BE ALL LIES TO GET
A WARRANT TO SPY ON A PRESIDENT?
AND THEN BLUDGEON A DULY-ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND TRIED TO REMOVE
HIM FROM OFFICE?
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OF
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OC
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OA
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OS
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OO
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OT
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OR
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OE
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT INTEL OD
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING TO SPY ON
THE PRESIDENT, PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN TRANSITION, AND OTHER
AMERICANS, TO CIRCUMVENT
AMERICAN LAW AGAINST SPYING
AGAINST AMERICANS?
YOU BELIEVE THAT'S ALL TRUE,
WHAT I SAID?
>> THERE IS A GOOD FAITH AND
REASON TO BELIEVE IT IS ALL
TRUE, BUT I DON'T WANT TO --
NEED TO TELL YOU IT'S TRUE.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT IT.
>> Sean: OKAY, WHAT ARE THE
ODDS THAT SEAN HANNITY IS RIGHT
ON THIS?
>> READ THE HOROWITZ REPORT.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THE ODDS?
>> I THINK SEAN HANNITY, I THINK
YOU BEEN RIGHT RIGHT ABOUT BOTH
OF THIS, SEAN.
YOURS IS THE BEST IN TELEVISION.
JUST TO STAY TUNED.
WEEKS FROM NOW, YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE THE HOROWITZ REPORT, AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO --
>> Sean: A BAD ACCIDENT IN MY
LIFE, SOME MIDMORNING READ AT MY
HOUSE, THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE AN
ACCIDENT, EITHER.
I JUST ASK YOU TO BAIL ME OUT,
SEND A CAKE WITH A FILE.
THANKS FOR YOUR WORK.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THIS IS NOT
A JOKE.
THIS IS LITERALLY AN ATTEMPT TO
RIG AN ELECTION, FAVOR ONE
CANDIDATE THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH FELONIES.
THIS IS ABOUT ON DOING AN
ELECTION, A SOFT COUP AGAINST A